bon vous êtes un vous êtes un pianiste
réputé darry cowl à paris but est non je
suis quand même je jouais bien je jouais
pas mal ouais mais je vais vous faire
une interview piano bar
vous
ouais interview
titouan d'harry 2
darry cowl vous trouvez pas que c'est
chiant les gens qui par le pianiste
pendant qu'il joue comme ça qu'ils n'ont
non sa mob ou au contraire vous puissiez
continuer à jouer quoi en général quand
on trouve un piano comme ça je joue plus
de piano de l'âge improvise comme ça je
ne trahis pas le composite
ah oui vous jouez en fait cesser votre
composition vous auriez quoi bon un
mariage par exemple
c'est original
et pour un enterrement vous auriez quoi
je jouerai une chose plutôt lente
il ya longtemps vous êtes pianiste ici
ici dans l'émission ça fait cinq minutes
vous débutez en fait c'est tout j'ai
tout neuf
allez vous commencer là et ça
olé
dites moi c'est vrai daric avant d'être
pianiste de bar vous deviez du cinéma
c'est vrai il paraît que vous avez plein
de films 157 ha bon dans 152 trop un bon
d'alcool
oui